the other thing that's gotten carly all
fired up is a chinese social media app
called
pinduoduo is that how you that's
probably not how you say it in actual
mandarin and like mandarin
they they they didn't be like pinpoint
like they kind of do it really fast at
the end but i don't know i don't speak i
don't understand
[Music]
um so i'm the wrong person there but
tell me about this app and why it's
taking over the world
going over the world okay i think i
think it's
i recently learned about this and again
it's connected to me actually to the nft
conversation because it's all about
social commerce right so this blending
of
our social media lives and our shopping
lives essentially or our spending and
buying
lives and china is
eating our effing lunch and this is just
another example
of this or in life in life and this is
a this is a microcosm example of why in
my opinion
so let's i'll start with like the two
elements of this that i think are cool
so essentially this is an app it started
off as like almost like an agriculture
buying
platform so you bought food and like
fruit and things like that as opposed to
just a general commerce app but they've
expanded now to be in like a whole bunch
of different goods
but they they have this concept called
team buying so when you go
on the pinwado app you see both an
individual price and then a team price
and the team price is lower basically if
you're going to buy in bulk
right you can get it for a cheaper price
so you either then can join an existing
team
like an existing group of people that
want that that
thing or you can start your own team and
like text all of your friends and be
like yo you want to go in on a bunch of
peaches this
week with me or a bunch of vacuum
cleaners or whatever the hell you're
doing like this is a cool product
and if they're like yeah you all hop in
and now you all get a discount
on this good so but but they're tracking
all of this data
obviously and so they're starting to be
able to map social relationships they're
mapping who has more influence they're
saying like oh wow
when this person sends their friends
like something in the you know
clothing like clothing related everybody
clicks on it a bunch of people buy
this person has a lot of influence in
clothing and so now the now the clothing
people instead of like going for
just the famous influencers we know they
can say okay this person has like
micro weight within their friend group
and within their social circle
we'll target them with our ads it'll be
a little more expensive to target them
because they'll share with them all
right and they do it by segments they
say this person's influential in
clothing this person's influential and
fruit and there's probably an algorithm
that's showing it on real time when
people are
oh wow so it goes it speaks to
how much data andrew talks about this ai
is like gets better and it's like eats
data
and so the more data you can feed it yes
the more data you can feed it
the more it grows the stronger it gets
etcetera and
this is just another area where china is
getting so much freaking data
that's really interesting and social
mapping their entire country
um and you know look there's drawbacks
too i'm not i'm not excited about this
i'm like oh this is awesome
all this data about us is forever going
to be available but um
it is really interesting the second
component to this app that's like the
social component the social commerce
component to it
is the gamified component so within this
app is a game
it's called like orchard the printable
orchard and you like
tend to this garden you tent you like
grow your fruit
it's like you know whatever one of these
kinds of games but at certain levels you
get then
free deliveries they'll just send you a
free box of fruit
so you actually win real prizes off of
the app from playing this game
so like you know it just it consolidates
like everything you want to do
in a place where you also shop so they
just are are
you know they're giving you every
incentive to shop and spend more money
and it's it's fascinating i mean
the advantage i'll say the one advantage
that china has over a place like the
united states well there's many but
on something like this is they subsidize
shipping so this is where you can have
members of a team from all over the
country and you can still get this
discounted rate and they can ship it
you know government shipping for all
their companies yeah
and it's something like that for some
reason shipping for them is is a lot
cheaper than it is for us here
it's actually there's something kind of
archaic about the fact that yeah
instagram shows us a lot of ads about
things we want to buy but you click that
ad you get taken off of the instagram
app
onto another website and that we're
gonna see that start to go away
this is my prediction is like you're
gonna see
commerce be more directly integrated
into these social media apps more and
more
where you're buying directly from that
social media platform you're not
clicking something and
being taken to another site and like
kind of moving you out of
whatever you're in it's going to become
all one experience
do we know if this is going to come to
the united states
um i don't know i don't know um
i will tell you this is a fun thing
guess how many users
they they started in 2015. guess how
many users they have
700 million wow very good 788 million oh
look at me
look at that that was impressive wow but
damn that's a
that's a load that's i mean more than
the you know like
more than double the population of the
united states uses
and i think that's weekly users or
monthly users like that's
regular active users it's like 700 plus
million people
craziest book i've read on
the future of china and ai is called
ai superpowers by uh
kaifu lee and you say a couple things so
one of the things is
um china is better situated
for mobile payments um than the united
states is and mobile payments are so
so valuable for ai and for data
gathering because
let's say i'm just going to chipotle and
i bought something if i do with a credit
card there's only so much info but if i
do it with my phone
they know all the data that's on my
phone my
shopping habits my actual geo-targeted
location
my gender zip code income you know all
those things right and so there's
just more data around what your purchase
so they can tie the purchase to who you
are and your
and your buying habits and things like
that and so the united states
we went from cash to credit cards very
easily
that's a really that's an awesome jump
right like it's like okay instead of
carrying all these bills and coins and
crap like having a credit card
way easier that's awesome um
going from credit card to your phone in
the united states like
it's a bit costly to change like you
have to like put your phone on if
your credit card the phone like you guys
would use apple pay or other things
right
and what's the real benefit you're
probably still carrying a wallet
um it's not that much better than
carrying a credit card it's slightly
better and there's a
bit of a cost so like it's it's slowly
adopting here united states
china had never really gotten to credit
cards they were still in cash so the
difference between cash
and wechat is massive so instead of
using cash they can put their bank
account on wechat and so they've gone to
mobile payments
fast and that is the big difference in
terms of how much data they're getting
ai
um and the second thing that blew me my
mind in that book
is this concept that um
kaifu lee flipped on said i love your
thoughts on this they flip he flipped on
his head the concept
of american hustle today in
2020 when he wrote it or 2021 you felt
touched today
not as in the movie starring jennifer
lawrence she was in a movie called
hustle
american hustle oh she's in that that
was bradley cooper was the star
and bradley cooper and jennifer lawrence
yes i forgot choosing that you know i
see you i
i say i love j law i just think of other
movies when i think of her
um she and bradley cooper did like three
in a row together that was one of them
anyways continue
you think they dated that was always the
rumor i think he was in love with her
the like
word on the street is he was in love
with her and she rejected him ah good
for her
so kaipu lee said this he basically put
this notion that american
entrepreneurs or this american hustle
where like we work harder we got that
american spirit like we're going to kick
ass the cowboy mentality like
work work work around american ingenuity
people go it's like
so he's like you think you work hard in
the united states like you guys have all
like in these big startups we have at
facebook's or google's you have like
you know like nap rooms and all these
cushy snacks and like
wonderful work-life balances you're
talking about three-day weekends which i
you know we've been a proponent of all
these things he's like
in china like you started a company like
a facebook
or any sort of startup in china you're
sleeping on the floor of the office
making no money and working all day
every day okay
let's be very clear that was what
happened at google and facebook in the
early days like do you do
like the early google guys talk a lot
about sleep but he's like this is more
ingrained in the culture i suppose
america there's like an exception where
there's like yes
people still do this united states but
this is like everybody in the u.s
in china like this is the dna and what
he said
which is even deeper than that point
because that point you can debate back
and forth but he's like
in the united states when we have a
minimum viable product
we have a product people like that's
growing we
declare victory when you create facebook
we're like facebook's awesome zuckerberg
on the cover of forbes magazine or
whatever you want
victory we have it yay america yay mark
yay
people investing in that great company
declare victory
in china when you have a minimal viable
product they declare war
and he's like the and that's right for
sure yeah
and they just start trying stealing each
other until and the real
what he argues in the book is at the end
of this war
the company that comes out of it because
people just stealing each other's ideas
and fake and like so someone make
the example would be like someone make
facebook.com someone would make
facebook.com
or a typo that's like facebook with 2ks
or whatever it is
calm and a website looks exactly the
same get all the information making
competitor immediately
um and so but the companies that come
out
of this war have a bigger moat around
their business to make them
in some ways unbeatable because they've
like they've had like
legit street fights does it to exist
um so it was fascinating
i mean look he blew my mind and then he
talks more about it but like talking
about the culture of
china and how they're going to win the
ai super war arms race if you will
um mind-blowing and this is another
absolutely
let me i'll say 100 i absolutely think
they're going to win the ai
arms race and it's their they're going
to become
the superpower because of it i will say
it's interesting because i'd read a book
many years ago called tiger woman on
wall street about this
this woman from i think shanghai ended
up going to middlebury
ended up getting to wall street um going
going into all you know going
on to wall street whatever getting a
finance job um and she
painted the lack of ip law and the lack
of infrastructure around ip law in china
as
actually something that was going to
keep it from being able to dominate the
united states
this you know this was all an analysis
sort of an absence of ai this was many
years ago
but her argument was look there's no
incentive to be
like to innovate essentially in china
because the second you
sink a lot of money into r d like
research and development and you build a
great product
somebody's going to come along reverse
engineer it steal your idea so why would
you even
bother why would you bother innovating
to begin with so that's why
i think we it's a it's a double-edged
sword you know i read this book probably
i mean i don't know how long ago now
probably a decade ago and i i do think
some of it has remained true but i think
that
this additional point of like okay but
no it's actually meant that like
the people who survive or the companies
that survive are like mega companies i
think
clearly that's borne out too and that
was that was not something i was
thinking about
we don't need this endless human
suffering of toiling the
the fields if you will or just like
we're all work work work work work and i
always thought switzerland had it right
where they like get one or two big cash
cows of new
inventions and new companies that come
out of there but they also have a great
social safety net and people are
generally content and happy now it's
easy to run a country of
how big a switzerland and like that's
someone who's you know you could argue
as a workaholic saying this um
but i you know i do think it's um
work money success they don't correlate
to happiness really
at all at a certain point um so it's
it's an interesting talk about human
experience but i love
carly's take pin du duo keep your eye
out for that kind of general principle
the way you've described this i want
this app i want to play foreign discount
or i want to get discounted stuff maybe
instacart will get into this that'd be
[Music]
great
[Music]
you